Donald Trump is now falsely claiming
that he stopped Ford from leaving
Kentucky for Mexico through a couple of
tweets the other night here's the first
tweet that Donald Trump put out just got
a call from my friend Bill Ford chairman
of Ford who advised me that he will be
keeping the lincoln plant in Kentucky
know Mexico then Trump also sent a
follow-up tweet about this issue saying
I worked hard with Bill Ford to keep the
lincoln plant in Kentucky I owed it to
the great state of Kentucky for their
confidence in me let's dig into this any
reasonable person sees these tweets and
things Oh Trump in some way is
responsible for the decision that Ford
made to change plans from moving their
factory from the u.s. to Mexico right so
there's sort of two assertions implied
there number one
Ford was planning on moving a plant from
the u.s. to Mexico and number two Donald
Trump did something to change Ford's
plans so what is the truth of these two
assertions made by Donald Trump well
let's just go to Ford and look at the
statement that Ford made which I will
put on the screen for you today we
confirmed with the president of the like
the president-elect that our small
Lincoln utility vehicle made at the
Louisville assembly plant will stay in
Kentucky we are encouraged that
president elect Trump and the new
Congress will pursue policies that will
improve u.s. competitiveness and make it
possible to keep production of this
vehicle here in the United States
now then Ford was asked did you have
plans to close this plant and move it to
Mexico and Ford said no we never had a
plan to close the plant in question so
number one Ford never planned to close
the plant in Louisville Kentucky they
were considering moving production of a
particular model the Lincoln MKC out of
Louisville but the plant was never going
to close so what about the Mexico stuff
well earlier this year Ford said they
had plans to shift small car production
to Mexico
Trump slammed them on that the thing is
that hasn't changed
Ford uh Ford's mark fields told Reuters
on Tuesday we're going to move forward
with our plan to
production of the Ford Focus to Mexico
this is a triple lie number one Donald
Trump did not convince Ford not to close
the plant and go to Mexico number two
Ford was never going to close the plant
and go to Mexico and number three
Ford was always going to shift
production of small cars to Mexico and
even after speaking to president elect
Donald Pat they are still going to move
the production of the small cars to
Mexico three lies here from Donald Trump
yeah I think this is really just a
marketing ploy to buy the Ford Motor
Company because Donald Trump has been
railing against them for years now on
the I am pain trail and so this is kind
of them extending out an olive branch
and Donald Trump just fell for it hook
line and sinker these are the kinds of
wins and I use the term wins completely
satirically they're going to be touted
by Trump and then considered as examples
of making America great again by his
supporters this is why it's really
difficult to get an incumbent president
out of office because this is just a lie
from Trump Trump had nothing to do with
any of these decisions and Ford is still
moving part of the production to Mexico
but now there are many Trump errs
trumpets that believe that Donald Trump
did something really really great